jeff bezos will remain influential at
amazon after he steps down as ceo
becoming the company's executive chair
reportedly focused on
which areas amazon will move into next
you expect to see amazon
to venture into businesses where they
feel like
they can disrupt the landscape by being
more customer oriented customer focus
so healthcare education all these things
will be areas where we have lots of pain
points
the world's richest man bezos is
estimated to make about 2
300 per second more in one week
than the median worker at amazon makes
in a year
his 1.6 trillion dollar company paid no
federal income tax in 2018
instead receiving a 129 million dollar
tax rebate from the government
bezos and amazon have become a symbol of
21st century inequality
farmer teacher paying 22 percent
amazon and 90 other major corporations
paying zero in federal taxes
i'm going to put an end to that but
unlike companies such as facebook
polls show amazon is trusted by the u.s
public and respected for its competence
even as it's accused of exploiting its
workers and having too much power
not just in its ability to squelch all
the competition but as a result of all
the information it's able to gather
about its customers habits
one commentator noted quote jeff bezos
has won
capitalism whatever the public's
feelings about bezos his vision is
astonishing as
is his desire for amazon to be
incorporated ever more deeply into
all aspects of society but a key
question for many has long been
why what is bezos's goal what does he
want
those who have studied him say the
answer is nothing less than the human
conquest of the universe
his primary ambition since his youth a
former girlfriend once told reporters
that it was this that drove him to amass
so much
wealth his idol is captain picard of
star trek
bezos had considered using picard's
catchphrase make it so
as the name for what would become amazon
bezos's decision to shave his head
has been noted in this context however
he's yet to outline an amazon prime
model of human existence in future space
colonies
there's a lot of one-upmanship if you
will in those kind of
super rich billionaires minds to make
the next
impact so space is the uh next frontier
and so uh they
may be very honestly believing that they
can make a much
a greater impact by exploring and
contributing to the faster development
of humans colonizing our humans
exploring
and becoming less dependent on the
planet and bezos will soon attempt to
achieve his goal of space travel
it's one earth i want to go on this
flight because
it's a thing i've wanted to do all my
life
a petition has attracted tens of
thousands of signatures pleading with
him to remain there
but a more realistic goal for those
concerned with his so far unchecked
power
may be the growing bipartisan
congressional support in the u.s
for breaking up his empire shia britancy
al jazeera washington